My two were bled on Monday and I couldn't stop it.
We went to the ER and still at the hospital.
This person, I hope you saw in that questions
that we answered last week.
I am starting my first radiation treatment this afternoon.
Oh, that is fantastic.
That is great.
Glad to hear that.
They are suggesting radiation and chemo together
or what are your thoughts about chemo.
You really want to talk to the oncologists
and say, OK, well, I know you want me to do chemo.
How was that going to give me any better chance?
There's nothing wrong with pinpointing them down.
They won't let us give any statistics
because they're the gods that have all the statistics.
Well, then pass them the statistics.
How do you think this is going to actually improve my life?
Is this going to, you're saying this, if I do chemo,
you're going to give me another month to live.
But I'm going to live a horrific existence for that month
because I'm going to be so sick.
So just ask them those pin-pointed questions.
They're the ones asking you to do something that's
going to make you sick.
So you have the right to ask them those questions.